are you nervous how many years had it
been uh I don't know 30 years maybe
weren't you a little nervous when I
still do this the first day uh I shot
was I shot with Patrick and we were on a
stage playing checkers or chess or
something I haven't seen it we looked at
each other we go this is both very
strange and not strange at all all at
the same time yeah it felt very natural
this third season of Picard of working
with all my friends again people ask you
know was that a weird or strange or
difficult or it wasn't it was you know
it was very easy because we we know each
other really well we're all friends
that's what Jonathan says it was
important for me to believe that you
guys just all really enjoy each other
you travel together to do cons or you do
uh you know a cruise and you do it
before you have lunch or we just talk on
the phone or we you know we see each
other it's not easy instead you don't
get sick of each other no not at all